Today we're learning English with
Disney Pixar's animation Cars!
You'll learn lots of driving related
vocabulary that you can start using now,
as well as better understanding
the American English pronunciation.
Because this is what we do every week.
Three times a week we help you to learn
fast English without getting lost, without
missing the jokes and without subtitles.
Just like Amir who says that our Disney
playlist is growing and he loves it but
he also actually loves all of our lessons.
So make sure you hit that Subscribe button
and the Bell down below, that way you will
not miss a single one of our new lessons.
I hope you enjoyed learning with Cars today, but
before you watch without subtitles and test your
knowledge with some quiz questions make sure you
head on over to our Instagram: @RealLife.English
because we publish lessons there every single
day so you can continue learning with us.
Not only that but I'm also there every
Thursday LIVE with an exclusive lesson for you.
So make sure you follow us there and I hope
you'll be joining me in one of the lives soon!